[Musique]
en 2019 le monde de la mode pleure la
disparition de Karl Lagerfeld en
s'éteignant l'icône de la fashion laisse
derrière lui une fortune assez
conséquente une fortune qui l'aide au
total à celle de ses proches et en tête
de cette liste qui vient d'être dévoilée
on retrouve le mannequin Baptiste
diabiconi que le couturier a repéré dans
un magazine et qu'il a pris sous son
aile le jeune homme enchaînera ensuite
les défilé à ses côtés je suis
l'héritier principal de Carl ça c'est
une vérité mais entre bien immobilier
diverses sociétés comptent en banque
multiples et œuvres d'art cet héritage
est complexe et ne cesse de faire parler
seul certitude aujourd'hui en étant le
premier héritier le mannequin hériterait
de 30% du montant total de la fortune
car Lagerfeld
il faut qu'on explique les choses parce
que voilà Jean-Marie pendant les images
animées pourquoi est-ce qu'il est hérité
donc faut qu'on raconte toute l'histoire
s'il vous plaît
direct il a fait un testament et dans
son testament il a désigné des gens dont
voilà qui est le premier le premier sur
la liste et qui va avoir 30 % de
l'héritage alors combien alors
l'héritage avait été estimé au départ
aux alentours de 200 millions d'euros
quand même mais il y avait des dettes
alors les dettes ont été purgées il y a
eu deux ventes aux enchères 22 millions
d'euros d'être purgé et finalement
pourquoi ça traîne parce que il est mort
il est décédé en février 2019 parce que
c'était quelqu'un de secret il y a des
comptes bancaires qui n'ont pas encore
été trouvés
en tout cas voilà il y a des il y a des
secrets de de Karl Lagerfeld il avait
plein de maisons il avait plein de
maisons des maisons des biens des
oeuvres des bateaux etc des bateaux donc
on estime que ce serait 240 millions
d'euros minimum comme Baptiste gerbiconi
on a 30%, il aurait 80 millions voilà il
va il va donner 50% office français
je crois que c'est 60
en gros il va peut-être devoir de l'eau
la seule somme qu'on connaît vraiment
c'est la gouvernante qui va avoir un
million cinq d'euros pour c'est la même
que celle de du joueur de foot
alors qui sont les autres
Sébastien c'était le collaborateur il a
démarré garde du corps c'est lui il a
été mannequin et Jerry aussi de Karl
Lagerfeld et que j'ai eu tout à l'heure
que j'ai appelé parce que c'est un pote
il me disait
d'avoir un bébé
mais non et je lui demandais s'il y
avait des polémiques si dans tous les
héritages dans tous les histoires il y a
toujours des polémiques etc et il me
disait que franchement il y avait aucune
histoire que ça prenait du temps parce
qu'effectivement il a plein de de bien
et de compte bancaire un peu à droite à
gauche et que le fils etc ça prend du
temps mais qui avait aucun problème
entre eux il sait pas et il m'a dit
qu'il avait découvert non il m'a dit
qu'il ne le savait pas et que Karl
Lagerfeld ne lui avait jamais dit que il
serait sur son sur son héritage et il
l'a découvert un jour à la suite de la
mort de Karl par le coup de fil d'un
d'un notaire qu'il a appelé pour
l'informer qu'il était sur son testament
après c'est beau ce qu'il a fait Karl
parce que les gens qui étaient lui
remercier il y a une légende c'est
vachement bien qui aurait donné de
l'argent à son chat là
[Rires]
franchement j'aime pas les gens mais je
le prends chez moi celui-là hein faut
pas faut pas qu'il a gardé Lyon celui-là
il est mignon le chat
c'est fou ces gens qui viennent bosser
chez les gens qui ont tous très beau dis
donc
il y a un autre mannequin aussi il y a
le une des directrices de la maison
Chanel je crois
lui c'est le parrain de son fils il y a
même Caroline de Monaco qui aura droit à
des objets
c'est le père du du de son filleul ah
d'accord il a un filleul qui doit avoir
une douzaine d'années et lui c'est
bon
et il y a oui il y a la nouvelle
directrice artistique de la maison à
vendre
d'un coup il est mort en trois morceaux
je veux dire que non mais que tu sens
que tu vas partir moi je dis que c'est
pas mal de son vivant de faire la
distribution
va arriver après tout ça
alors
tu enlèves 120 millions d'impôts
d'imposition quand on est pas en ligne
dire quand on est pas y avoir que ça
doit être ça
il reste quand même un peu à manger
c'est dommage la mode mais vous auriez
même pu rencontrer Liliane Bettencourt
c'était encore mieux genre ok
bon on sait jamais
rencontré une femme très riche c'est
dommage c'est dommage vous êtes fait
plumer quoi chaque fois moi j'avais
rencontré une qui était milliardaire qui
était vraiment milliardaire et qui était
amoureuse de moi c'est une catastrophe
totale je raconte dans mon livre et
malheureusement ça m'a coûté une fortune
bah oui parce que forcément elle elle
était habituée à vivre sur un très bon
pied évidemment et donc du coup dès
qu'on sera plutôt clairement
OK
et du coup le soir par exemple je
passais elle avait un très grand
appartement sur les
et j'allais dîner chez elle j'ai dit on
fait juste un apéro à la maison je dis à
très bien ça me va etc et puis vers 11h
elle dit oh puis non viens on descend on
va manger un petit un petit bout je dis
à très bien on va où ah bah on s'emmerde
pas il y a la maison du cavi en bas
d'accord voilà ils ont le caviar 2500 €.
évidemment moi gentleman c'est le métier
et elle s'attend elle réglait pas elle
se connaissait pas mes problèmes
d'argent en fait et donc
je régler difficilement mais souvent
elle est pas simple
mais le banquier a fini par m'appeler en
disant mais ce maire il y a un problème
faut qu'on se voit quoi bah oui
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans votre vie
quoi et du coup je l'ai quitté j'ai pas
osé lui dire que c'était une question de
la journée j'aurais dû l'épouser
peut-être
très bien
c'est adorable et adorable qui qui a
hérité ici comment tu as été de quelque
chose irrité
dans tout petit peu de d'argent
comme on dit de la de la cuisse gauche
quoi
et vous moi j'ai hérité
mon père aussi
moi j'attends avec un chat
[Applaudissements]
comment est-ce que ça nous rendrait plus
heureux oui on est heureux aujourd'hui
plus d'argent oui la réponse est oui oui
oui
parce que l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur
aujourd'hui comme ça aussi et puis voilà
si ça vient pas bien sûr bien sûr